foreign
IST Sheila Swift has been battling
chronic obesity for many years nothing
seemed to work but nine months ago she
was prescribed an appetite suppressant
drug and has lost six stones since then
feel amazing
I'm I'm happier in myself
I'm physically able to do more I wasn't
able to I can run up and down the stairs
rather than take one step at a time the
name of this miracle drug oh
oh
ozempic an injectable initially designed
to treat type 2 diabetes is a brand name
for some aglatide which works by
inducing a feeling of fullness famous
users like Twitter boss Elon Musk credit
the drug with their weight loss so too
has Boris Johnson the former prime
minister wrote of azampic how for weeks
I jabbed my stomach and for weeks it
worked I must have been losing four or
five pounds a week maybe more before he
stopped due to side effects the results
are in for week five are news and pick
ozempic is everywhere on Tick Tock and
its explosion and popularity is
partially why there is now a massive
shortage of the drug both in Ireland and
internationally I'm now on the hunt
driving around Ireland like somebody
who's looking for
illegal drugs
to try and find a pharmacy who might be
sympathetic that will give me the
my next month's Supply
just like many patients we had to drive
for more than an hour today simply to
find a pharmacy that had any stock of
ozampic here it is despite potential
side effects including diarrhea nausea
and vomiting this remains one of the
most in-demand drugs anywhere in the
world today
pharmacists liked happy Marr here in
County meath don't know how much is epic
they'll be allocated from month to month
it's really challenging and really
upsetting for people if they can cut a
medicine that they need to treat their
condition you don't know how much you're
gonna get pharmacists have no idea it's
almost a Christmas morning on the first
of the month when I see what comes in my
my deliveries for my wholesalers now
obesity patients say they're being
shamed as pharmacies reserves scarce
stocks of ozampic for diabetes patients
I am getting feedback from patients both
struggling to access the drug and
feeling a little bit second-class
citizen when they're in the pharmacy
trying to get reasons as to why they
can't get the drug the drug maker Novo
Nordisk expects shortages to remain for
the rest of this year it may not seem
like billionaires and influencers of any
trouble getting the drug but ordinary
obesity patients like Sheila will for
now continue to battle both stigma and
scarcity
Stephen Murphy Sky News in Dublin
[Music]